nous avons été exploités en permanence malades
maintenant c'est cool mieux là-bas que l'
oignon aldea étaient jeunes
haha mais vous avez dit que faire de l'argent
tousser quoi
e neuf où sortez-vous ici qui l'a trouv
les billets sont merci pourriez-vous p
enser avec leur  vand
intrusion sur le chemin de fer Chut les
gens scrupuleux de quelqu'un là-bas obligeant les enfants
à faire leur sale boulot ne veulent pas que vous
alliez là-bas produit chimique normal obtenez notre
câble pour la violence probablement environ 500
livres finca par Alva c'est trop risqué
allez vous faire un repas
ton gosse je veux mieux pour toi et
s'ils continuent tu vas te faire truquer
frappe le ici mais je ne suis pas toi même tu as vu
je me ralentis